hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar how
pipetting can change the way beverages
are tested
a shared perspective for femsa and
sartorius
i'm alexis krause of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labberts
and brought to you by sartorius to learn
more about our sponsor
please visit their website at
sartorius.com
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box located on the left hand side of
your
screen and click send we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical issues here as
well
for example if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i would like to now welcome our speakers
gabriela sanchez the senior demand
planner at hugo cevalle santa clara
and palos artimo product manager for
pipetting and dispensing at sartorius
a leading international partner of the
biopharmaceutical industry
and the research sector gabriella paulus
welcome to both of you gabriella you may
now begin
your presentation
hello everyone thank you for the
introduction
the topic today is how electronic
pipette
can test your beverage for you
the agenda today is microbiological
processing with micropipette
then microbiological processing and
at the end benefits of electronic pipes
is part of the coca-cola femsa group the
coca-cola femsa group is the most
important bustling company in mexico
we manufacture beverage paths joists
nectar isotonic drinks meal
vegetable meals tea flavor
beverage or products are focused on
different
market segments kids sport
beverage and nutrition
as you can see on the slide it shows the
timeline of fogo del valle
through a time starting on the year 1940
24th when people from santa clara used
to make
home delivery meals and 23 years later
officially google television was found
on
1947 and star operation
antipoteplant plan who is the main
boston jewish
and isotonic beverage
majedtime who was elevated diversified
the products and made the introduction
of twist off systems
opening a border and pouring into infant
levels
introducing the aluminum percussion and
start selling
half hallow meal and a gallon meal in
mexico
other important events occurred
at 1992 when zacatecas plan star
operation
the second one most important processing
plant in mexico
publo del valle continues grow growing
up
acquiring branches at florida siete and
santa clara branch
launching of steam vitamin water and ice
cream
flavor after 2007
when juvo del valle was acquired by the
coca-cola company
continues acquiring branches focused on
nutrition as
for mark
production process next
i will explain a little bit about the
production process
inside fuco del vagi first of all
fruits are revealed to the plant washing
procedure starts
after nectar extraction bottling
volume and presence of strange materials
is checked
metallic particles plastic or organic
materials
quality culture for approval of final
distribution
including physical chemical and
analysis and microbiological analysis
these analyses are carried out in a
coca-cola laboratory
in florida united states announcement to
the plants in mexico with their approval
for use
pioneers in innovation the innovation
has been
a constant in order to remain in the
preference of consumers
easy openly creative packing option
aluminium can mini bottles
triangle boxes thanks to the variety of
packing
size and flavors we ensure the quality
of the products
and the issue used by users no matter if
it is a
children or an adult
how electronic a can test your beverage
for you
a second topic microbiological processes
microbiological process depending
on the consistency of each sample the
seeding method will be classified
about 60 percent of beverages are
processed
by the slit to other methods this method
consists
of taking two milliliters of aliquot of
finished products
people in a petri dish and later adding
the culture
media in the microbiological laboratory
we use
the orange serum media for acid tolerant
micrognis
rba for total coliform and pda for total
acetophilic
as this method is one with the most need
generate a high workload and the use of
stereo pipettes is also verified
looking for alternative to reduce
cost advantage of
pico's electronic pipette versus
exterior disposable pipettes
low cost there were problems with the
knobs due to skill
required to use it making the routine
work
sometimes complicated the high numbers
of hours required
made the process slow time versus cost
one box of steric pipettes 500 pieces
are equal to buy 2000 tips
easy handling easy to use the use of
pico's pipette makes easy fast
ergonomic repeatable and reproducible
the daily work reduction of cross
contamination risk
it was very useful to clean material
areas
and devices to avoid cross contamination
especially surrounding areas the uses of
bonsai
burning is frequently dangerous this is
solved
with the use of sterified tips
because implement in our procedures
guaranteed success in the last four
years
easy to use no matter the sample for our
for our very viscous products with hype
full content the pipetting is easy and
the samples are
as easily dispensed as water
the pipette is very light facilitate
operation
especially with high volume of samples
to be processed
per day since the implementation of
pico's micro pipettes we have not had
reports of
injuries or discomfort due to the
expenses or liquids
with work routines the sartorius
pipettes are comfortable and intuitive
use
easy to change and clean it allows an
easy change of wall volumes and sample
timing
cleaning the sartorius pipettes are very
easy to clean
and autoclaving service
i feel support by both seratorial
customer
and technical service they support us
in preventive and corrective maintenance
calibration
and training all year round thank you
thank you gabriella for your insights
all right hi i'm paulos
and i'll be now diving us deeper into
the benefits of electronic pipettes
and some of the features that that
gabriella was was
introducing to us
but to help me set the scene i'll start
from the very beginning
so pipetting is the most common lab task
and accurate pipetting is the basis on
which most lab work builds on
and and pipettes are positioned
measuring instruments that require
extensive training and and hands-on
experience to produce repeatable
and accurate experiment results
most laboratory professionals have
picked up their first pipette during
studies with limited to no training and
have learned on the go
and have had to learn the hard way um
here i've got two graphs and on the left
we can see
um results of of uh from 53
biopharmaceutical quality control
technicians and their individual skills
in
pipelining accuracy and precision uh in
in dispensing small volumes
and and you can see how how there's a
huge variance between
the the different individuals here
in in a group that you would think uh
would be on the top of their game and
and uh have a very precise results
um the the group was then um trained
uh in in formal training
for for pipetting techniques and and the
results after the training can
can be seen on the right and now you
should see what you expect from from
professionals to
to uh have really accurate and precise
results and and the whole group
uh were able to have reproducible so the
whole
lab tree would now be producing
reproducible
results and and this
really shows you why it's important to
have formal pipetting training
because only with proper training can
lab professionals
produce these sort of repeatable and
reliable results
um but the pipetting technique consists
of of knowing the proper basics
so basics like what angle the pipette
should be at
what depth to aspirate from and and
where in the dark
the target vessel to dispense to also
how you should handle your specific
liquid take it into account
viscosity uh for example volatility
temperature and and uh specific
attributes like like um in induced
pipetting juice the the pulp content
but also handling of the pipette and
especially how the piston movement
uh is is controlled manually
so the last one
requires the most practical experience
and and here is where electronic
pipettes can step in
the graph shows three different groups
and how you would expect that their
pipetting performance shows
so the first group the inexperienced are
people
that are new to pipetting the moderately
experienced are laboratory technicians
and the experts that we use here
are accredited service technicians
and and there's a clear correlation
between the experience and and the
variation results
and and you can see the smaller the
pipetting volume the
higher the variation with the
experienced
group is
but with an electronic pipet that that
relieves the professional of the piston
control the results
show smaller variants between operators
so on the the graph on the right
all of the three groups and then used
electronic pipettes
to do the same sort of experiment and
and there's
practically no difference between the
different volumes
but also between the different groups
but how does the electronic pipette then
really do this
so when using a mechanical pipette the
more experienced users have
sophisticated piston control
whereas for the less experienced ones
it's uneven
and and maybe a little bit jerky and
this affects the accuracy
and position um and
and this is uh one of the major error
sources recognized by the
the uh iso standard
uh on air displacement pipettes but the
electronic pipette gives reproducible
results because the pipette volumes are
imprinted
independent of pipelining experience as
hand control is eliminated it's it's
that the piston is controlled by an
electric motor
but we still need to
follow up with the proper pipetting
practices
such as the pipetting angle aspiration
death
pre-wetting of the pipette tips so so
really
as electronic pipettes have um can
can be a very a good tool
to uh harmonize uh results
but you still need um proper training
get best possible results
so there really are two main pipetting
principles
um this forward pipetting normal
pipetting or just
pipetting that people are are used to
calling it
where the target volume of liquid is
aspirated into the tip
and the tip is completely empty to do
during dispensing
uh this is corresponding to the left
picture the
a1 so there's the amount of liquid
uh coming into the tip how we set the
pipette
but the second a very powerful technique
is is reverse pipetting
which is on the right there the picture
b
where you see that there's a little bit
more liquid inside the tip
on the right
um so the target volume
uh with an extra amount is aspirated but
only the target volume is then dispensed
so how is this done let's look at it
from a mechanical pipette point of view
so you would actually
press the the piston all the way down
to a second stop then you would aspirate
the liquid
and release the the piston to the to the
top and when you dispense you only press
it to the first stop
leaving a little bit of liquid inside
and and
then you can re uh discard this this um
rest of the liquid and next i'm going to
show you why this is powerful and
explain
what's the advantage coming from this
technique
we need to be thinking about this
because this is
one of the principles or the main
principle behind
the most of the pipetting
modes of the electronic pipet beyond
just
normal pipetting and reverse pipetting
so let's think about some difficult
liquids like viscose liquids such as
syrup
which can be a problem when pipetting as
they have a higher resistance to flow
and a higher tendency to stick on deep
surface
now reverse pipetting an electronic
pipette smooth dispensing techniques
compensate for the liquid liquids
tendency to adhere to the tip
walls so when we look at the graph
we see that with forward pipetting the
dispensed volume jumps
up and down with visceral underlap after
about five pipettings with the same tip
but with reverse pipetting and
multi-dispensing the results are good
already from the first times
and this because the amount of viscose
liquid that sticks to the plastic walls
of of the pipette tip are actually
reduced from the excess amount
and we we still dispense the full target
volume
while having some of the liquid stick
to the walls and you still get
the accurate target volume that you're
looking for
but everyone who has worked with with
xyrep knows also that
speed plays a role here
so an electronic pipette allows for
setting the best speed
and to harmonize the speed between users
here the the graph shows
three different example speeds
of the big pipette speed number one
is the slowest speed 8
would be close to what you would expect
from a mechanical pipette user pipetting
water
so the power of the electronic pipette
is that you can set the speed
and it will be the same in the morning
after lunch and also uh once you start
to feel tired
uh during the shift but
also the speed will be the same for
everybody
so now with a mechanical pipette there's
this um
everybody's personal pipetting practice
how the like
it's like handwriting and then we remove
this
by setting the um electronic pipet
settings
the same for the same liquid for
everybody in the lab
beverage labs usually work with sugary
and viscose liquids
so the first is bad for teeth but both
of them are bad for your pipette
so if the liquid enters the interior of
the pipet
they will need cleaning and might
require maintenance which is
why many labs choose to use filter tips
but with filter tips an important thing
to note is that your liquid shouldn't
come into contact with the filter
so you might not have thought about this
but if you're only using forward
pipetting
but with reverse pipetting and the
pipetting modes of the electronic
pipette this is very important
the pipette tip should have enough space
to hold the entire volume
without the user having to worry about
the liquid touching the filter
as this would impair the repeatability
of the results
now some manufacturers report the
maximum volume that their filter tips
can hold in reverse pipetting
as it is lower than the nominal volume
or they the
maximum volume of the tip so
look up the choose fiber tips
that that are designed to have extra
space
and allow using the entire volume range
of the pipette because when you're using
the electronic pipette
you don't want to restrict yourself and
think about okay
what's the maximum volume that i can use
so here in this video you saw us as a
pipette
with with four different uh filter tips
the the liquid into the tip and and with
the the three ones on the right you can
see that the liquid touches the filter
so these uh these aren't suitable for
for
say full volume multi-dispensing or
reverse pipetting
but the the safety space filter tip on
the left with the extra space
uh has plenty of room uh
so in case there even might be some some
bubbles or foaming
uh you still don't touch the filter and
and
lose any of the sample or the accuracy
but now if you don't think filtered
pipette tips are necessary
you might consider pipettes that are
compatible with so-called safeguard
filters
these filters are inserted into the
mouth of the pipet
and will protect the pipette for about
50 to 250 pipetting cycles so you don't
get any splashes inside
the pipette and and thus
contaminated or require further
maintenance
one of the main reasons why people
switch to electronic pipettes
and something gabriella also mentioned
that they really appreciate
is the ergonomics of the pipette so the
first thing that might come to your mind
with
about electronic pipettes is that they
must be large
and heavy to accommodate for for all the
technology
but now think about your own pockets and
how much smaller your
your average phones have become although
they have even
more and more technology so modern
electronic pipettes
is the same weight and size of a
mechanical pipet which makes it easier
to adopt
them
but really the ergonomic highlight
is is the electronic operations
by just with the press of a button
you can do all of the different
functions of the pipet and from a
repetitive strain point of view
the best feature can be the electronic
tip ejection
as tip ejection is the single most
forced demanding step
in the pipetting cycle
it might not be straining as an
individual event
but as you can see here in the graph
there's
quite some force required to do this
so here there are six mechanical
pipettes and there are ejection forces
including the mechanical tactup pipet
next to the tip ejection force of of
sartre spicos
so they're from 30 newtons uh
two to 11 or 12 newtons with the the
mechanical pipettes when you have to
press a button
and and drop the tip but now with an
electronic pipette with just the press
of a
a a a small button
you you can eject the tip
and and the difference is
like third newtons doesn't sound 33
newtons doesn't sound too bad
but after you repeat it multiple times
like hundreds times
it accumulates
um and and let's look at the whole
cumulative force per pipetting cycle
so a single pipetting cycle which
includes the aspiration
the dispensing blowout in case of
forward pipetting
and also tip ejection is reported here
for an electronic pipette
and a mechanical one now the electronic
pipette
with the electronic tip ejection reduces
the force
uh by about 85 percent
and the difference when you when you uh
take into account
all of the different uh the hundreds of
pipetting cycles you do
so um you're really looking at whether
you want to do
uh 1400 newtons of work versus 10 000
newtons of work
and this is something that that is is
the reason why
why uh when gabriela mentioned that they
they don't
see or or they don't get reports of hand
complaints anymore because when you
switch to electronic pipettes the the
amount of work you need to do with your
hands and and your fingers
is is significantly reduced
finally the electronic pipettes also
give us the possibility to ensure
that everyone in the lab is following
the same procedure
uh to the point uh that we can save the
settings into it
so some pipelines also allow for saving
whole workflows which will help save
time
and promote best pipetting practice
so i've got an example for you so quite
a common pipetting workflow
you might use is a dilution series
so my method here has a ratio of one to
three dilution
in multiple steps i begin with
dispensing the diluent of water
to sample tubes then i thoroughly mix
the starting sample
dispense it to the next tube again mix
and transfer
and i could save this protocol so
there's no need to change the settings
every time and remember that different
speed settings that are optimal
um and and you can use any and all
pipetting modes of the pipette
and create just the right setup for your
method
and and it's also possible that that
you can choose a pipette that that
allows for password protecting this
so so you can uh integrate your
method your your standard operating
procedure
into your pipette
save it and and and protect it from from
anybody inadvertently changing it
so only those with authorization can
change it
so what i want you to take home is that
electronic pipette can reduce the
variance inside your lab
promote the best pipetting practices and
take everyone to the expert level
but the ergonomics as well so it will
protect the user's hand
from hand paint and reduce the effect of
fatigue to results
it can also speed up your work help
protect the workflow
so it's done as it should be every time
i want to thank you all of you for your
attention
and now we'll have time for your
questions
thank you gabriela and paulus for your
informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started we've already got
some great questions coming in from the
audience
so palace we're going to go ahead and um
and start with you
here's our first question we also have
liquids that have high pulp content and
we have a problem that the pipettes get
clogged
we sometimes cut the tips so the pulp
passes through
what would you recommend
so so thanks for that so this is uh this
is something that that's more common
that
than than one would expect so but
actually
cutting the pipette tips has a huge
effect on the accuracy
so i would recommend instead that you
try
so-called wide bore pipette tips so they
have a larger opening
with these tips you could stop cutting
the tips and so
saving you time but in case you're
just transferring liquid and the the um
the actual volume or the accuracy
doesn't doesn't count then
then the cutting tips might be a
possible but anyway checking the
whiteboard tips will will save you the
convenient
convenience of it
great thank you so much so much palace
and looks like we have another question
for you
so we sample high viscosity liquids and
it is difficult to get all of the liquid
out
how can i solve this issue
um so there's a couple of things um
you could try uh first of all um
i i recommend using the reverse
pipetting technique that i
talked about just now with it you get
the right volume
and and as you don't totally empty the
tip out
it's it's easier to get the the
target volume out of it
also as men should pipe it really slowly
so the liquid has time to come out of
the tip but but also
think about low retention pipette tips
um as as the sticky liquids won't won't
be
adhering to the plastic
um you get more accurate results and
it's easier to get all of the
the liquid out
great thank you so much um this audience
member
mentions you know i've worked in the lab
for over 10 years but i've never had
pipetting training other than from what
i've received from my colleagues
does sartorius or do you offer any type
of training program
yeah yeah so we do and actually this is
something that's
that's um something we we encounter
quite often that that people
uh are are not receiving formal training
but so um part of this offers this
this um training uh concept so-called
pipetting academy
um you can contact us to arrange a
training session for your lab
uh for for say basic pipetting
techniques uh going into more depth than
than
i i went just through now uh there's
also
piloting ergonomics uh private
maintenance and
and many more so we usually arrange this
sort of trainings
at customer sites um for for a larger
group
uh but but during the the uh pandemic
uh we've had also good experience in
virtual training so
so um you should you should uh contact
a local uh representative and and book
your
yours for for your lab
thank you palace now moving on to our
next
question are the sartorius pipettes
autoclavable
yeah um so so you need to to
take care here so some of them are so
the starter is mechanical pipettes uh
prolan plus and mline are fully
autoclavable
the proline mechanical
is not it's an older design and with
different
materials used and also the the
electronic pipettes
so the lower parts are but don't put the
handle with with all the electronics
in an autoclave so if if autoclavability
for the pipette is really important then
then the electronic pipe at night might
not be the
choice for yourself so check the uh
fully autoclavable
uh pipettes that we offer
great thank you so much i do want to
remind our audience um
that any questions that you submit today
and that we're not able to get to
or any questions that come in during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by our speakers via
the contact information that you
provided
at the time of registration so let's go
ahead and move on to
our next question this this audience
member asks
is there a way to protect pipettes in
sides from splashes
uh yeah so so there are a way so of
obviously the the first thing is is to
use
proper uh pipetting technique and uh
and um not go into that sort of
speeds that that you would get splashes
but i i briefly mentioned
um the soil called safecon filters
uh and and these are the filters that
that you would actually insert inside
the
the tip cone of the pipette and and this
protects the
the insides um
and and it's it's a it's a really nifty
um accessory for it as as uh
it keeps the pipette better and and if
if there's uh
new people in the lab or or something
that we really
recommend for the um
student labs uh in academia uh to
to uh use this so you never get the the
liquids inside so and it's easy to
change
but remember to change this every now
and again the filter isn't
isn't the ultimate protection it needs
to be changed
so so uh so look into this
great thank you so much it looks like
we've got a couple more questions from
the audience today
so now what would be the best way to
clean the pipettes after use
so so the pipette should be cleaned on
the outside
um they they
tolerate uh most common
um cleaning agents uh but but
you should check if if you got something
really a little bit more
stronger that you want to use um
so so for sartre's pipettes check the
cleaning and decontamination guide that
we offer
and and when it comes to more thorough
uh
cleaning where we're going to
launch this or publish this
pipette cleaning guide uh it's a video
that's that's coming
and and that that tells you more about
the the uh internal part cleaning
so you don't have to leave the the the
cleaning to the
by yearly or or once a year maintenance
call
call that you or send when you send them
to calibration
great thank you so much for that for
that explanation palace and
it looks like we have time for one more
question
so our last question palace goes right
back to you
can i use other than sartorius pipette
tips
with my sartorius pipette
so so the sartorius pipettes work best
with our own pipette tips as these have
been designed together
but there are other brands that can be
used but you should
carefully look into about the
compatibility
and and you can't just determine the
compatibility while
by by testing the physical fit but you
really need to check the performance
and and to see if if the performance
that you get with the system
uh is is um good enough
for for your needs so so there is
um nothing that you could say this sort
of
universal pipette tip so there's always
this design
differences so um look into this
uh we recommend the sartorius pipette
tips but but
uh in case your lab is using something
else uh you could
you could try this but remember to to
verify it uh with an analytical balance
and and through your calibration
great thank you so much and we would
like to thank you again
gabriela and paulus for your time today
and your important research
we would also like to thank leopards and
our sponsor sartorius for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by your speakers via
the contact information that you
provided
at the time of registration so please
keep those questions coming in we are
happy to answer all of them for you
sartorius will be sending in an faq
following the broadcast for any
questions you may have missed during
today's webinar
this webcast can be viewed on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time thank you for joining us
bye-bye everyone